Психологічно я просто не могла дихати.
Я просто не могла дихати!
Я забувала їсти, забувала, що дітей треба годувати.
Для мене оці перші три місяці - я не пам’ятаю, що я робила.
Якщо я зараз впаду духом, що буде з моєю дитиною?
Як би це не було важко, тому що ну…
Цих українок об’єднують різні втрати:
рідних, житла, роботи і загалом колишнього мирного життя.
Усе це забрала в них війна.
Тепер вони вчаться заново долати труднощі та опікуватися дітьми попри невідомість майбутнього.
Доброго ранку, сину! Цілую й обіймаю тебе!
Такими відео Володимир щоранку вітав 6-річного сина Бодю з фронту.
Доброго ранку, сарделько!
Дивися, як треба!
Та найбільше Бодя любить ось цю колискову під гітару,
яку тато зіграв на відео з Харківщини.
Спи, маленький козачок! Повернися на бочок!
Люлі-люлі! Баю-бай! Прийде завтра Миколай!
Усі ці численні відео - цінні спогади чотирьох дітей Володимира про їхнього тата.
Минулого року він посмертно отримав звання Героя України за захист Харківщини,
де загинув, рятуючи побратимів.
Дружина Галина не може описати,
як жила перші три місяці після звістки про загибель коханого.
Я забувала їсти, забувала, що дітей треба годувати.
Для мене оці перші три місяці - я не пам’ятаю, що я робила.
До туги за чоловіком додалася відсутність роботи і стрес у малечі.
Відтепер Галина мусила виховувати чотирьох дітей самотужки.
Богдану сказали, він там щось перепитує через рік:
"А коли війна закінчиться, тато точно не прийде?
Його ніяк не можна вилікувати?".
А старші - вони вже це розуміють.
Син замкнувся в собі. І дочка.
Щодня психологічний стрес переживала і Галина:
мала проблеми зі сном.
Втім, каже, не наважувалася звернутися по допомогу фахівців.
Доки подруга не порадила волонтерський проєкт реабілітації.
Мені подзвонили і сказали: "Тобі треба".
Якщо я спокійна і врівноважена, то і дітям легше.
Волонтери запросили Галину та її дітей на проєкт реабілітації "Кемп+" у Карпатах.
Разом з психологами родина вчилася жити заново:
готувати улюблені страви, танцювати, ходити на прогулянки й головне
- говорити про свій біль зі спеціалістами.
Раз, два, три, чотири - жили миші на квартирі!
Три тижні арттерапії, індивідуальних консультацій та командних занять…
Зараз Галина та інші учасниці продовжують займатися з фахівцями
у київському центрі фонду "Голоси дітей".
Сьогодні кожна з них проговорює, що її тривожить, на груповому сеансі терапії.
Після обмінів всі мене починають питати друзі:
"Ну що там? Які в тебе новини?"
А мені й так важко, що мій чоловік не потрапив у цей обмін.
Це - Марія, жінка, що разом з десятирічною донькою
втратила рідну домівку у Маріуполі та друзів,
яких в окупації вбили росіяни.
Та найгірше - каже вона - втрачено зв'язок з чоловіком,
що вже понад рік перебуває у полоні після оборони "Азовсталі".
Життя в прямому сенсі розділилося на дві половини.
Останнє, що Марія чула від свого чоловіка телефоном
перед його здачею в полон - вона повторює зі сльозами на очах.
Ми просто прожили 15 років у цивільному шлюбі.
І перша його була фраза "Ти вийдеш за мене заміж?"
А я кажу: "Нам що оце нема про що поговорити?".
"Звісно, вийду! Тільки повертайся!"
Тоді жінка ще не знала, що вони розлучаться надовго.
У місті тривали вбивства цивільних.
На виїздах з Маріуполя російські військові проводили фільтрацію.
Евакуюватися автівкою було неможливо.
Ми пішли пішки в невідомість.
В нас був будиночок у передмісті, який залишився від бабусі.
Потім з’ясувалося, що там з самого початку базувалися орки.
Вони звідти стріляли.
Дитина - важко, бо коли виходили з міста, вона бачила трупи,
вона бачила весь цей жах.
Психологічно я просто не могла дихати.
Я просто не могла дихати, не могла проходити поруч.
Після евакуації з Донеччини усе пережите Марія
наважилася вперше розповісти психологу.
Одна зі складових терапії - віднайти з фахівцем заняття, що мотивуватиме.
Так разом з донькою під час групових сеансів на кемпі
Марія захопилася плетінням маскувальних сіток для ЗСУ.
Ми живемо за таким принципом:
"Що ми розповімо татові, як ми його чекали?
Що у нас не було просто суцільних сліз!"
Любимо наших дівчаток і дуже дякуємо за такі подаруночки!
Вони нам відправляють не тільки свічки, а і теплі речі!
З гордістю відеоподяки від воїнів ЗСУ
за маскувальні сітки та окопні свічки переглядає і Наталія.
Завдяки волонтерству вона також долає посттравматичний синдром
внаслідок повномасштабної війни, яку зустріла на Луганщині торік.
Чоловік 24 лютого 2022-го - пішов на фронт,
а вона - з дитиною на руках застала обстріл будинку,
з якого дивом вийшла живою разом з малечею.
"Доню, ти розумієш, прийшли погані дяді, зламали наш будинок,
зламали твій садочок, наш тато зараз виганяє їх з країни".
Сказати їй, що вони прийшли нас вбивати, я не могла.
Була така ситуація, ми їхали в автобусі, сидів військовий в бронежилеті, з сумками.
А вона: "Він їде на війну?"
Хоча, при ній слово "війна" я ніколи не говорила.
Для мене стан дитини - це дуже важко, коли вона ставить такі питання.
Їй не вистачає тата, вона тягнеться до всіх чоловіків.
Сьогодні з Наталією поруч немає 6-річної донечки
- та постійно вдома - у тимчасовому житлі, яке їм надали благодійники.
Дівчинка досі долає наслідки стресу і боїться людних місць
- через це під питанням її вступ до першого класу школи.
Коли ми виїхали, вона місяць взагалі мовчала, вона не розмовляла.
У неї були панічні атаки.
Завдяки їй я тримаюся, тому що я розумію,
якщо я зараз впаду духом - що буде з моєю дитиною?
Якби це не було важко, тому що ну…
Наталія публікує у соцмережах вірші зі звертаннями
і до українців, і гнівно - до росіян.
Що ви від нас хочете! На свою землю назад йдіть!
Такі, як Наталія - пройшли довгий шлях аби проговорити свої історії
і прийняти власні емоції від пережитого - розповідає психотерапевтка.
У цьому і полягає частина терапії.
Ми шукаємо їхні ресурси.
У кожної людини, в української жінки є ці ресурси,
але вона просто розгубилася, забула.
Ми розповідаємо, як відбувається стрес,
що таке стрес, що з нами, що з нашим мозком, які реакції нормальні.
У всіх виключно людей, які зараз в цьому році з нами працюють,
приїхали в кемп, невротичний стан діагностовано, десь у десяти відсотків ПТСР.
Усього психологічну реабілітацію у цьому фонді пройшли понад 200 дітей та 180 дорослих.
Найчастіше люди приходять на терапію тоді,
коли вже мають критичні проблеми зі сном,
розлади харчування, апатію або панічні атаки.
У дітей - помітний регрес у розвитку.
Були у нас випадки, коли діти розмовляли, володіли мовним апаратом,
знали слова, але трапилася якась подія, яка їх відштовхнула на півроку-рік в минуле,
дитина перестала розмовляти.
Фонд "Голоси дітей" надає також гуманітарну
та правову допомогу дітям та їхнім матерям,
зокрема з оформленням необхідних документів і пошуками нового житла.
Ми допомагали евакуюватися родинам, поселяли.
Працюємо за індивідуальним запитом.
Ми ніколи не віктимізуємо дітей, ми показуємо, що українські діти -
стійкі, талановиті, творчі, але вони живуть у війні, і їм потрібна допомога.
Головне - кажуть жінки, які взяли участь у проєкті
- це нове відчуття внутрішньої сили.
Його вони отримали, коли наважилися розповісти свої історії фахівцям.
Ти не одна. І є ті, хто може допомогти.
Ми одне одну підтримуємо. Мене розуміють.
Люди, які щось не пережили - не розуміють того, що ми переживаємо.
Галина після втрати чоловіка повернулася до роботи
- вона вихователька дитячого садка.
Її мрія - створити власний освітній хаб для дошкільнят.